in east london there is a building it's
known as the cathedral on the marsh but
this is no house of worship
it's a monument to london sewers
[Music]
opened in 1865 the crossness pumping
station was one of the first of its kind
in the world
designed in the romanesque style the
victorian masterpiece was built to
tackle london's struggles with raw
sewage and cholera outbreaks which
killed up to 20 000 people every year
the plant is a testament to beauty in
both form and function almost every inch
is adorned with immaculate ironwork
long pillars support the top floor where
four steam-powered beam engines rest
weighing 47 tons each
the station was part of a system devised
to collect sewage water and discard it
in the eastern part of the city away
from the centre
despite there being other regulations to
reduce sewage at the time the station
has been praised for pushing london into
a healthier less smelly future
as english capital has moved to new
solutions to keep its water clean and
flowing this sewage cathedral is
maintained as a museum showing that even
the dirtiest of jobs can inspire beauty
[Music]
you